madame la Première ministre vous
soumettez au Parlement de façon
successive des textes sur l'énergie qui
ne font toujours que des dispositifs
d'ajustements sans jamais donner
réellement de vision d'ensemble sans
jamais avoir réellement fixé un cap
clair plus que des doutes aujourd'hui
nous avons des craintes il y a deux
semaines lors de votre déclaration sur
la politique énergétique de la France
vous avez indiqué travailler à
identifier les réacteurs nucléaires qui
seront fermés à l'âge de 50 ans pour
tenir dans les décennies qui viennent il
nous faudra pourtant tout mettre en
oeuvre pour porter notre parc nucléaire
au-delà de 60 ans les annonces que vous
avez formulées craindre que vous n'ayez
pas changé de cap par rapport à la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
que vous avez fait voter lorsque vous
étiez ministre de l'écologie et qui
prévoyait la réduction à 50% de la part
du nucléaire dans notre mix électrique
madame la Première ministre pouvez-vous
nous confirmer que vous avez bien pris
en compte le discours de Belfort du
candidat Macron et changer d'avis par
rapport à 2019
[Applaudissements]